okay we've been talking a lot about
autonomous vehicle technology and I was
reminded of this pretty interesting
interview we did a couple years ago with
Paul Moller who has a flying car
prototype and flying cars were you know
decades ago the idea was by now we would
definitely have flying cars and I
actually don't think that it's because
of lack of technological advancement
that we don't have them I think that
there are so many other impediments to
flying cars Paul Moller
answered many of my questions some of
which I recall him finding slightly
annoying but that's okay he still
answered them back in June of 2015 we
will go now to my interview with Paul
Moller about his flying car prototype
I'm joined today by dr. Paul Moller
president of moller International and
also someone who has been developing a
modern flying car really for some time
now dr. Mohler when did you first start
this project well I was inspired when I
was five after viewing a hummingbird but
I think the project probably was
seriously started when I was about 15
and attempting to build my first
helicopter and what is the the status of
the project currently well the project
involves many ARMs because we have both
unmanned technologies like the drone
industry which is very popular at the
moment and we have high-speed vehicles
vehicles that you would use as a
commuter in the future and then we have
low-speed utility vehicles much like the
jet Sevilla chol that gets you from you
know a utility vehicle Border Patrol
vehicle rescue vehicle one that speed is
not important but utility is so I would
say we have a number of projects
certainly one of the most important is
that we're into engines of an unique
nature these engines really make
everything else we do possible these are
what we call a rotor power rotary engine
power being the big issue as it is for
the hummingbird and you think about it
the hummingbird apparently can consume
its own weight in a single day
taking off vertically does require a
great deal of power and that's really
been the problem historically as to why
you don't have a flying car in your
garage at the moment yeah and
you know there have been different
people including engineering experts and
aeronautical experts who have weighed in
on your project and they said we don't
know that this is really possible the
way the way dr. Paul Moller is
approaching this where I'm sure you've
heard those detractors what's the
current status do we have is there a
prototype at what point in the process
are you
well we've demonstrated all of our
technologies repeatedly so we've done
something and no one else has done we
actually flown them I've flown them
personally we've never felt comfortable
enough to go out there and make an
excessive public display certainly we've
had press people president some of our
flights but we want or were waiting for
the ability to do an international press
right where we have a level of
confidence in the aula security methods
that we have employed to make this safe
and we're working very hard at that at
the moment multiple levels of redundancy
on all components so that when we get in
front of public there's not a
catastrophe because this technology is
very unforgiving when something goes
wrong in the airplane you use you have
the capability of gliding to the ground
certainly a fairly reasonable capacity
of survive but vertical-takeoff aircraft
during the harbor mode like the
helicopter below 200 feet when it's
hovering there is no recovery so we do
it to redundancy we do to multiple
engines multiple computers multiple fuel
tanks multiple fuel pumps everything you
can ask for we have multiple elements
this is a there's a complicated system
in itself but it ends up being a very
reliable system and if people want to
take a look at images of what we're
discussing just google the Moller Skycar
mo ll er talk to us a little bit about
you mentioned that it uses a rotary
engine what would the top speed of this
vehicle be when flying through the air
well I'll always refer to two different
vehicles the sky car being the more
streamline high speed certainly more
expensive vehicle if one were to buy it
and then the lower speed vehicle which
would call the new error the sky car has
a top speed of roughly 300 miles an hour
at 25,000 feet okay we have not flown
there yet but we have flown it in wind
tunnels we've flown around computers we
know that we have the capacity to do
that and then the other vehicle which
never goes faster than a hundred miles
an hour but is something that everybody
can use a rancher Border Patrol and a
paramilitary application any
recreational application these two
vehicles fit two different roles both I
think which are going to be a big part
of the future what's the highest that
you've actually flown the prototype well
high enough to kill myself how much I
can say but probably not in excess of
100 feet anything about 10 feet becomes
very dangerous so really again probably
I'm leaving at a very risky world but I
went after many years ago and I think
it's a little late to change my path and
why do you think that this has been such
a long process as you said and as I've
read you've been on this path for about
50 years we've been hearing so you know
about the sort of amorphous idea of
flying cars for a long time you know 100
years ago people thought by the year
2000 we might have flying cars why has
it been such a long path for you well
it's a long for anybody and again I
emphasize the requirement for the
powerplant is very unique you need to be
able to produce at least 2 horsepower
per pound right now we're producing 3
horsepower per pound
we need 1,200 horsepower and a 2,400
pound vehicle try to try to think of
that possibility now if you go to very
large rotors like a helicopter you cheat
now let me I don't need to interrupt dr.
Mohler but you I want to make sure we're
clear on the numbers you said you need
to produce two horse
our per pound and then said you needed
to produce 1200 in a 2,400 pound vehicle
but don't you mean 4800 in a 2,400 pound
vehicle no I mean 1200 horse barn a
2,400 pound vehicle our engines in
effect weigh 600 pounds and a 25 they
weigh about a third of the weight of the
vehicle actually we do better than that
now that we've gone above that but the
bottom line is you don't have any
engines that other than our engine or a
perhaps a similar engine if someone
chooses to develop it that makes it
possible to get these kind of power
levels in a reliable package the rotary
engine which is fundamentally what we're
talking about the same kind of engine in
a way at least from the family of the
engines used in the Mazda has the
ability to produce a huge amount of
power in a small package it gets into
the region of what the turbine can do
but the turbine engine is a very
expensive engine it will always be an
order of magnitude more expensive than
the engines were using so economics
enters into this certainly you see the
military flying vertical-takeoff
aircraft all the time you could call
them flying cars if you like I'm
certainly they could produce what's
called a flying car but they would also
have an engine that costs a million
dollars that's really the problem how do
you get this high amount of power in a
lightweight package and not have it cost
so much that it never would be available
to the public in any reasonable way and
what do you think that that one of these
flying cars would need to cost for it to
be sort of economically viable as a
transportation method for but you know
not necessarily the average American but
even upper middle class well I think
that it would have a very substantial
market at $100,000 but I think I think
it's possible nice I'm sure we can show
that in economic production levels
similar to that of a single model over
the automobile industry which in the
case of the Mustang for example was a
quarter million vehicles a year we would
certainly be in the area 50,000 I don't
think there's any issue about that
because the only real cost to our
vehicle is the engine ours our control
system is so very simple because the
engine does all the control so that's
really the bottom line is the end
determine the cost and right now we're
in the engine business more even more
than or in the aircraft business because
we have conditional orders for five
billion dollars of engines and if we can
produce engines on a high-volume
economy a scale means the Skycar is
going to be inexpensive it's the driving
force behind everything safety and cost
yeah and talk a little bit about safety
I mean in reading in about the sort of
viability of the consumer flying car it
seems safety cost and and the impact of
whether you know we're not talking about
a commercial airliner with ILS and other
instruments this navigation systems
necessarily are we whether would be a
big factor well I think that you've got
to consider that this vehicle will
basically be flown automatically at all
times in a in an environment where
there's a lot of other vehicles so
you'll be in the highway in the sky with
virtual Highway as you probably know the
airliners are landed more often than not
by automatic landing today in fact the
faders have typically been when it's
manually controlled the automatic
landings by commercial airlines has been
far more successful in the manual
landings so we're in a world where
automation is far safer than the human
in terms of the reliability consistency
perhaps the better way to put it and so
yes you'll get in this vehicle you'll
drive it
and when I say drive it I mean it's
treatable you drive it to avert a port
or a heliport is this call today you
code in your destination and and you go
to sleep you read you played computer
games whatever you choose to do on the
way you can rearrange somewhere along
the line to go to a different
destination but you certainly are not
going to be at the controls and there's
no reason for you it's far far safer for
it to be all programmed in the first
place last thing on this as fascinating
as this is how far away do you think in
terms of a timeline we are right now
well it depends what level of vision you
have is what you consider this becoming
a commonplace vehicle we will have we
have the opportunity to have this
aircraft approved under new categories
that didn't even exist number years
go which make it easy to get the market
as you know the drone industry is now
allowed to fly up to 400 feet and if you
let people fly around without somebody
on board at 400 feet you certainly can
let them fly around at 400 people
somebody on board without a pilot's
license and without FAA certification so
that's a big step the next step beyond
that's what's called light sports
aviation category a special subcategory
for power lifts which our vehicle is and
that you can fly to 8,500 feet and of
course the final category is FAA
certified where we could fly to 25,000
so you have very various entry points
and that's very important getting access
to this market in a way that makes
anybody a candidate to use this vehicle
is very very important and critical to
this success so when I answer your
question
next year we will have vehicles on the
market they'll cost between two two
hundred fifty thousand fears and fifty
thousand because they're basically
hand-built at this time but boring has
studied this vehicle and many other
aerospace companies have looked at it
and I think there's a consensus that in
the volumes of the hundred thousand two
hundred thousand vehicles which a small
relative the auto industry it'll be down
around fifty thousand dollars truly
fascinating we've been speaking with dr.
paul moller molar international is the
company and you can google the Moller
Skycar
thank you so much for being on with us